I was reading that that you both went
into this series with with just a little
musical experience not a lot and now you
walk out as kind of rock stars how does
that one feel
I mean it's it's it is pretty amazing
you know I think we really came from not
being able to play anything on a guitar
or sing really to having a full record
coming out which is like crazy to us I
think
[Music]
I kind of don't believe either of you
I'm like you're not gonna make me
believe Riley just sang in the shower
you're not gonna make me believe Sam
never picked up a Guitar come on I know
it's true we were blessed with a lot of
time
um
coaches yeah we had a crazy team behind
us and hours and hours of rehearsal and
um anything's possible is what this is
a lot can happen with you know that's
the glass what was the biggest challenge
though for both of you in learning to
you know because you want to come across
as authentic because people will pick it
apart and they'll they'll see quickly
like okay they don't really know what
they're doing what's the biggest
challenge I think all of it coming
together all of it you know I think it
was it was like not only playing the
guitar but singing whilst I'm playing
the guitar whilst also trying to move
like I know what I'm doing and I've been
doing this for my own entire life whilst
also singing in an American accent
whilst also you know
um like running on no food because I was
trying to lose weight for the part like
I think there was there was so many
things like kind of that I had to sort
of contend with
um but honestly honestly like as Riley
said the amount of like
people involved in making this a reality
um you know the coat from the coaches to
the producers that everyone was so
supportive I think they had more belief
in me than I had in myself so it was
kind of
hard on himself
you know but anyway it was team effort
Riley um take
the first day that you
are months of jam sessions so we had we
had months of rehearsal so we were
basically
um in band practice for I don't know a
year at one time at band camp that one
time at band camp we it was a lot of
times the first time we sang together
was it Eric vitros oh yes we went to our
singing coach and Eric that was really
fun but we couldn't stop laughing
laughing like it's not the first time
I'd ever sung that closely yeah because
because we got in the room neither of us
have been singers he you know he put us
together and then was like okay I want
you to like look at each other and we
just were both like barely knew each
other and we were like oh I can't sing
it
um but we were it was very funny and
we're both gay I think I think there's
an image of us somewhere that's there's
a video I have yeah and I'm like
pretending I'm a rock star playing
guitar but it it all I remember from
that that session was actually see how
I was like okay well I'm not singing on
my own I feel less sort of naked I was
like okay I can sort of rely on someone
else I feel the same because up until
then it just been like me auditioning
alone and him auditioning alone and and
it was this moment of like oh we're both
bad
oh fear it's not just me I thought maybe
she's miles ahead of me I was like oh no
no we're both we're both yeah
so we blend really well Riley so what
does it mean to be continuing like your
family's musical Legacy in a series like
this wow I mean I I certainly wouldn't
put that pressure on it I I don't know
if there is continuing uh my
grandfather's Legacy
um it's its own sort of uh thing to me
um but it was a real
really fun experience for me I'm not a
musician all right I am now kind of you
are
um but I'm I'm I've you know been
interested in film my whole life and so
for me it was more um
really loving to get to um have a
relationship with music in that way
because that's not something that I'd
you know I I'd listen to music and my
whole family are musicians and I've been
around this world a lot and been on tour
and all that kind of stuff but I'd never
really
um done it myself so for me yeah it was
more about my personal relationship with
you know getting to play music which is
fun well if DNA is a thing and it really
like you got the rock star DNA and it
came flying out of you sis no for real
I'm not even I was like I get it I buy
it yes I get it well that was also
extensive rehearsal
can we talk about the fashion because
Daisy was everything and yeah all the
clothes I mean come on right it was yeah
how much fun was it I remember someone
saying it looks like you've just walked
from home and like
questions are just like denim jeans and
a denim chair uh yeah I very current but
seeing their fashion Journeys was was I
mean amazing mesmeric
correct
um yeah I mean it was so I mean that was
one of the most fun parts of this
experience for me along you know aside
from the music and learning you know um
to play and sing was the costumes and
working with Denise who did all of her
costumes for the show and the way that
she let me collaborate with her I've
never had an experience like that and um
the amount of references I mean it's the
70s so it's just like it was incredible
costumes and um we were sending each
other photos of chair and Joni Mitchell
and Stevie Nicks and
everybody we were just constantly
sharing photos and bracelets and tops
and shoes and going oh my gosh we need
to get this and it was so much fun and
you're making an album it's an intimate
thing
it has to be I've never seen him smile
this much in his life
can we get a season two see what the
bank if you want a season two you need
to tell Amazon
where do I sign up basically I'm a
resolution girl yeah I know it does
leave you hanging would you guys be in
if that thought ever came I I I actually
already pitched my version of series two
wow guys a long story but it's a very
long story I want to hear um yeah I
still feel like there's so much more to
to come but it's not for us to say maybe
Taylor Jenkins really needs to write
another book
foreign